i'm not one for predictions when i look
at this heat celtic series tonight game
two
uh heat wind a very entertaining game
one in overtime oh where's the block
uh
as i look at this
i think michael smith it is obvious
we're gonna be sitting here talking
about a game seven
in this series
so
promise me this mike
let's not overreact
to whatever happens celtics win tonight
jayson tatum gives you you know 34
points or something like that or jaylen
brown responds or kemba walker responds
if if the celtics blow them out have the
celtics taking control of this series
let's not do that old lame broadcasting
thing where you just take a snapshot and
you say oh this is what's going to
happen what's going to happen i don't
know if you agree with this
is that this series is going to game
seven it's just so even from top to
bottom i mean really if i wanted to go
up to the executive level
on one side we got pat riley as a team
builder who's just still getting it done
i mean pat right he's still getting it
done and then on the other side you got
danny ainge
you look at the coaches
eric spoelstra love them brad stevens
love them
best players
jason tatum jimmy butler
secondary players good so i just think
across the board i'll probably give the
slight edge to miami off the bench
unless gordon hayward comes back because
hayward
i saw the other day he's doubtful that's
progress
he's doubtful for tonight's game he was
out he sprained his ankle and that was
four weeks ago so now
he may have a shot of playing but you
agree with this it's a seven game series
man
no i don't i i don't i i think i think
they can be even on paper
and appear even coming in
and the series may not play out that way
i mean look at the heat wind tonight
okay i will promise you this not to go
into the old sports writer bag of
cliches i promise you that so i'm not
going to call tonight a must win for
boston because
they can certainly come back and
win two in a row and now we're back at
square one
however
if the heat win tonight
it would be hard just staying you know
just narrowing out focus to the seven
game series conversation that this game
is that the series is and these teams
are so evenly matched until it's
destined to go seven if the heat win
tonight
it's hard for me
to see the celtics
winning
three of the next four
in order for this to go to seven the way
the heat had been playing at nine and
one to this point in the playoffs yeah
and i think the celtics just given their
inability to close this postseason i
mean
look the block i'm still on the high
from them out of bios block i mean but
to your point about how close this is
they were up 14 in the fourth
so they could be good enough to get up
fourth fourth up five with a minute to
play
but but here's all i'm saying they can
be good enough to hang with miami and be
up 14 in the fourth and blow leads and
this could be if they don't get their
act together quickly and respond
accordingly tonight this could be a five
five-game series no chance no chance no
chance it's a five-game series uh look
and i know you hate this point that's
why i kind of bring it up sometimes to
annoy you
just being real
okay
you say if if miami goes up 2-0 tonight
well i don't see the celtics you know
coming back why when when the series
shifts to miami
no that's exactly
bubble
right
all right this is march madness this is
march madness in september i agree yeah
neutral court it's not going anywhere
and so now talent
talent is what we're judging it on we're
not judging it on hey you know they're
tough on their homes
i know do that again don't do that again
did you not just learn your lesson from
i don't know 24 hours ago you about to
do the whole they're talented thing
again
well you fell for the clippers bananas
that's right but where'd that series go
okay but that series still went seven
games now i was wrong i said the
clippers were more talented they're not
the nuggets are but it's a seven game
series
it's it's it's not like the the clippers
talent was that much more than the
nuggets and and vice versa same thing in
this situation if the celtics go down
two zip they can come back and they can
win three straight against this team
they sure can come on oh god no okay
you're disrespecting miami now
again anything look per let's let's the
baseline baseline for any discussion
certainly anything can happen okay
having said that i think you're
disrespecting miami by saying matter of
factly that the celtics can win three
games against this month this heat team
they're really good they're not fluky
they're not upstart it's not a cute
story of pat riley and eric spoelstra
rebuilding it so quickly after lebron
you know went back to cleveland they're
a complete
dynamic
dangerous teams you said rebuilding that
is that's funny that was six years ago
but anyway go ahead
that one's sick was this six years ago
already it was six years ago hey the nba
man look in the nba it ain't easy to
turn around and be in the conference
finals
in six years when lebron leaves via free
units ain't like they made a trade did
they no you know so anyway um no i i
think i this isn't a must win because
yes boston can get back into this series
but it's not a game you they were
captain obvious they certainly rather
not lose this against a team in miami
that i don't think is going to let up i
don't think jimmy butler lets this team
relax i don't think spo and riley let
this team relax against the celtics
that's all i'm saying they would have a
vice grip on this series if they were
that's who they are okay that's the
thing that's the thing i like about him